good morning it's seven o'clock today
chaos in kabul and political pressure in
westminster british troops continue to
face waves of people trying to escape
the afghan capital meanwhile the foreign
secretary faces allegations that he and
his team had no contact with the afghan
government as the taliban seized power
we'll talk to the armed forces minister
james hippie in just a few minutes
also this morning the fast and the
furious cricket we look ahead to the
finals of 100 with the birmingham
phoenix bowler adam milne
it's friday the 20th of august
desperate to leave thousands of afghan
people begged troops to let them on a
flight at kabul airport
they're trying to keep everyone calm
those of them have got the right to come
inside but at the moment they can't very
very tensive
on the ropes the foreign secretary faces
calls to resign as it emerges no one in
his team phoned the afghan government as
the taliban took over
defying the takeover afghans waved the
national flag to mark independence day
as protests against taliban rule grow
across the country
as the scramble to evacuate people from
afghanistan continues i'm live at rf
bryce norton where more flights are
expected
also this morning the climate campaign
of greta tumba claims the uk is leading
the way on climate change are a lie
so i'm really hoping that we will stop
referring to the uk as a climate leader
because if you look at the reality that
is simply not true
and the weather takes a bit of a
downturn as we end the week it looks
like being a wet weekend but next week
high pressure building so we're looking
at some more calm and subtle conditions
all the weather details coming up
shortly
[Music]
well very good morning to you the
foreign secretary is facing further
criticism as the security situation in
afghanistan deteriorates soldiers at
kabul airport are continuing to deal
with a mass of people including babies
desperate to leave the country after the
taliban took control and it's now
emerged that that phone call that
dominic raab the foreign secretary was
advised to make to help afghan
interpreters working for britain was
given to a junior minister but it still
never actually happened well let's talk
to our middle east correspondent
aleister bunker for the very latest on
what's happening in kabul because we've
had even more distressing images as to
haven't we from the airport
yeah and i think from the outset
we should say that when we show these
pictures as you say stephen they are
they are distressing and they show uh
again people who are in such a desperate
situation uh that they are handing over
their small children their babies uh to
british and uh american troops uh in
order that at least if they can't escape
themselves uh their children can be
taken out to uh what they hope would be
a better and safer life and
you know i mean you can't even imagine
what must be going through their minds
and the fears that they must be
experiencing in order for them to resort
to that kind of
a last-ditch attempt
but such is the chaos such is the
desperation at kabul airport these are
the scenes that we are now seeing uh
regularly and uh it is in part or no
small part because there are now more
and more reports
of taliban violence across the country
uh just to give you a flavor of some of
them um
zds that were massacred by the taliban
uh a couple of days ago i mean i won't
go into detail but it is grim uh the
german um news outlet deutsche bella has
uh revealed that one of its translators
uh has fled for his safety but his
family were hunted down by the taliban
and two of them were shot dead so it's
those kinds of uh reports and stories
that are putting the fear amongst afghan
people and making this taliban look very
different
to the words that they have been saying
in press conferences much more like the
taliban of old okay alistair for now
thank you
well let's talk to the armed forces
armed forces minister james heapey who
joins us now it's good to see you this
morning look can you bring us up to date
with the latest on that evacuation
effort
yes i can confirm that in the last 24
hours 963
uh people have been evacuated from kabul
on the royal air force average um that's
a significant acceleration on the
numbers over the previous 24 hours and
reflects i think that we're now fully up
to speed in kabul uh with military
border force and foreign office consular
staff all now up and running
and we're looking forward to delivering
similar numbers today tomorrow and over
the days ahead so on that basis how long
will the uk evacuation plan lasts
well i mean we don't have it in our
gifts to say that it will last for
another
five days 10 days 15 days it is clearly
circumstances that are very dynamic
we are simply doing our best to maximize
flow each and every day but as my
colleague the defense secretary has
sadly had to say on a number of
occasions the reality is that eventually
the air bridge will have to close and
quite possibly not everybody will have
been got out that's what keeps us awake
at night that's what's motivating to us
to work as hard as we are to ensure that
those numbers are the absolute minimum
i mean what what does other people do
who aren't at the airport at the moment
one of our correspondents has been
talking to the sahiri family from london
who 13 of them went over there for for a
wedding they're in kabul they can't at
the moment get to the airport
what are the options for people like
that
so i think i'd say three things if i may
firstly uh
our understanding is that actually the
taliban are not
uh turning people away uh where they
have done i've heard that it's more that
they are being officious rather than
malicious
and so if people are called forward for
flights they should have confidence that
the taliban will let them through uh to
the handling center we know that the
crowds outside the handling center have
been a barrier for many uh yesterday we
reconfigured uh the handling center uh
did some military engineering to try to
ease those crowd control challenges
which hopefully will increase flow and
then the final thing i would say is that
people should not despair that the air
bridge is their one route out of
afghanistan to the united kingdom there
will be a second phase to this operation
which will see people being able to
enroll at other british embassies and
high commissions in the region and to be
able to be resettled that way and so
even when the air bridge inevitably has
to close that's not the end of people's
chances of getting to the uk
i mean there are reports that contract
staff who protected the british embassy
and now getting no protection from great
britain labor calls that shameful
that's got to be looked at hasn't it
well if you're referring to the garda
world staff who protect the embassy i
can tell you that they
have arrived at the airport this morning
uh and we'll be moving them out later
today
so they they are now fully covered
yes yes
um in terms of of getting people out
that we have relied on
during our time in afghanistan i mean
why did the foreign secretary not take
our responsibility to get interpreters
out of afghanistan seriously enough to
take a phone call
well i don't know the exact details of
foreign office ministers call sheets
what i can tell you as the secretary of
state said yesterday
i know that no one phone call would have
been decisive in changing the trajectory
either for the collapse of the afghan
government or indeed for the
acceleration of the airlift
what i'm focused on is not recrimination
over who should and shouldn't have done
what when i'm focused every single
minute of every single day in making
sure that the military operation to
extract people from kabul goes as well
as it possibly can and that we leave as
few people behind as possible
but if you're focused on that every
minute of every day you'd expect your
colleagues to to do the same wouldn't
you if the foreign secretary wouldn't
make a phone call or take a phone call
and it's passed on to his junior and
that phone call still doesn't take place
if the defense secretary um said to as
he said
we knew that the afghan government was
melting like ice on friday and yet the
prime minister then heads off on holiday
on saturday i mean it does raise
questions doesn't it about the
commitment of your colleagues
i can only tell you what i see in the
meetings and phone calls that i have
all the way through every day have done
for the last week will do for the next
one and what i see is that from the
prime minister to secretary of state to
my junior ministerial colleagues around
government to senior civil servants all
the way down to the brave volunteer
civil servants who have gone forward to
cabal from the border force from the mod
and from the foreign office is people
across the majesties government working
their backsides off in order to get
people out i completely understand why
the media wants to
ask these sorts of questions it's
entirely reasonable but you'll forgive
me perhaps if i focus on the job at hand
and hopefully be reassured if i tell you
that absolutely every colleague at every
level be they political military or
civil service is doing everything they
possibly can to make sure that we get as
many people out as quickly as we
possibly can
i mean you served you've got a better
understanding of this and certainly a
lot of your colleagues who haven't
served and done a tour of duty in
afghanistan
everyone's talking about being
blindsided by this and certainly it was
a very rapid
operation by the taliban but um
it's emerged in a report submitted to
the government in january it laid out
how what sort of risks the u.s
withdrawal posed to all of this so
there's been eight months of planning
time
so why has the uk government let's
forget about every other country why is
the uk government been blindsided by
this
well i don't think i accept that
characterization of what's happened over
the last week absolutely we've been
blindsided by the speed of the collapse
of the afghan government and the speed
at which the taliban have been able to
take control but
there was a plan for the drawdown of
british troops in afghanistan called op
catalon that has been in place since the
beginning of last year because the doha
agreement that president trump signed
meant that on the 1st of may this year
in theory we were going to be leaving
and so we've had a plan for that all
along likewise pitting which is the
evacuation of entitled personnel and
those who have worked alongside us
that's a plan of long standing so both
of the plans that have been executed
over the last few months and are in
progress right now in the terms of
pitting have long since been devised and
we're ready to go the bit that's caught
us out and i don't think anybody uh can
deny this is that everything happened
far more quickly than we ever thought it
would
um as a
a veteran of of afghanistan
what did you make of general cynic
carter chief of the defence staff who
said on this program a couple of days
ago the taliban are country lads with a
a moral code not our enemy and i'm
i'm obviously
not quoting him directly there but those
are the words he said what impact does
that have on veterans what impact does
it have on the families of the
457
what impact does it have on serving
armed forces personnel
well i think that
actually to veterans and to serving
personnel um we're probably the audience
that gets what cvs was saying more than
anybody else because
you know the three operational campaigns
that i served in northern ireland iraq
and two tours to afghanistan
in northern ireland by the end people
like jerry adams and martin mcguinness
who had been in the ira were a part of
government in iraq people like muktara
al-sadr who was the leader
forgive me forgive me minister for
jumping in but we are a bit tight for
time look i've been in contact with a
lot of members of the armed forces over
the past few days they're not on board
with what the chief of the defense staff
was saying they're absolutely furious
morale is at rock
bottom and you only have to look at what
was posted on forces tv on when they
played out our interview
on on instagram and look at the hundreds
of comments below to see if people are
not on board with this whether they're
currently serving or veterans they're
furious
well i think you you should let me make
the point that i was making which is
that we get that when we go off to fight
we are
a means to an end but we are not the end
in itself and that very often the peace
that follows that is imperfect and just
as members of the ira are now in
government in northern ireland the
people who are leading the insurgency
that we were fighting in iraq are now
the key power brokers for a government
that we're working with in baghdad it
was always inevitable that the taliban
would be part of the solution in
afghanistan it makes me sick of course
it does to see the scenes that we're
seeing in afghanistan i gave some of the
best years of my life and i risked my
life
in afghanistan but when i was patrolling
in sangin in 2009 or in kabul in 2005 i
was doing my best to make a difference
in those six months to the lives of the
people that lived in those communities
what's happening now is for politicians
to answer for but the fact that the
taliban are part of the piece as painful
as that is for people like me who have
served it was always going to be the
reality
what would you say though to the mother
of a young soldier who lost their lives
in afghanistan you know i don't know
eight years ago
when they hear
cynic carter say these are country lads
with a moral code but i have been at
many military funerals i have held the
hand of bereaved mothers when they've
been presented with their elizabeth
cross
i have already many times had to look
people in the eye and reassure them that
the sacrifice that their son made was
not in vain i don't think that anything
that has happened over the last week in
any way detracts from what our brave
service men and women did in those
extraordinary years whilst we were in
helmand and my message to veterans
to the bereaved families of those who
never came home is that they should
continue to take pride in the bravery
and the sacrifice of their loved ones
because they did an amazing job whilst
we're in afghanistan nothing can ever
take that away from them politicians
will be held to account for the outcome
but nothing diminishes the bravery the
courage the determination the
professionalism and too many cases the
sacrifice that our people put in during
those difficult years in helmand
minister thanks for your time
thank you
well still to come for you this morning
has the west been too slow to respond to
the crisis in afghanistan we talked to a
former adviser to boris johnson and a
university researcher who's just escaped
kabul that's at half past seven
and
accorded away we'll be speaking to the
founder of the afghanistan national
institute of music
on the future of music under taliban
rule
and with dominic raab under pressure
over whether he did enough during the
collapse of afghanistan we talked to
labour's shadow security minister connor
mcginn at five past eight
now thousands of people are still
attempting to get into kabul airport
british soldiers are working almost
alongside the taliban to find british
citizens and those who worked for uk
forces amongst the crowds
our chief correspondent stuart ramsey
reports
a sudden calm outside
for a moment no soldiers just us alone
with hundreds seeking refuge well not
quite alone
the taliban are doing security
every day this place gets stranger and
stranger
amongst the crowd british passport
holders waving to us unable to come
forward told to stay where they are
there are lots of british nationals and
residents and europeans as well here
waiting for their turn inside
they've taken days to get to the gates
many have the paperwork they all say
it's been absolutely horrendous and
dangerous
i've been stuck here for the past two
days i'm trying to get in i went to the
americans they pushed me out they kicked
me out i went to the germans they beat
me up with the sticks they fired us
you see these uh gas fires that they
make you cried yeah take us
the fire with the gas and everyone was
crying right here like an hour ago
the tear gas in between the kids you see
the kids they're like one years old kid
how can you put together the americans
is that the americans yeah and the two
good the americans the germans they're
two rupees they beat our people with
baseball bats
while the british soldiers are trying to
deal with large numbers of uk nationals
and people cleared to come to britain
who should be at the american base not
here
getting them to the right place is a
logistical nightmare protecting them and
the base from being overrun is hard
the paris form into a defensive square
trying to keep the crowds calm urging
people to sit
all ages are here all confused tired
upset and desperate
[Music]
for now at least the british relief
effort has to pause to let the american
relief effort continue well the crowds
have got so close now not
can't available very tense here very
very tense because these people are
desperate
in single file the evacuees heading to
america are brought from one camp and
directed to another
whole families attempting to escape the
new taliban emirate of afghanistan
there are always so many children
hopefully they're too young to know what
an earth is going on
children too amongst the crowds at the
moment blocked from entry into the place
that could be the gateway to a new life
or if they're british their rightful
home
from the compound a helicopter lifts off
ferrying the refugees to the military
airport their next step on the journey
to freedom from the taliban
stuart ramsey sky news kabul
well let's get the latest down the
flights evacuating people out of
afghanistan's capital our correspondent
charlotte lomas is at raf bryce norton
forwards and so in the last few minutes
we've finally had some confirmation
on the figures nearly a thousand people
out yesterday and and wanting to conf to
continue on on that sort of level for
the next few days
exactly good morning to you stephen yeah
we heard uh then that's 963
people have returned from afghanistan in
the last 24 hours we know that the uk
government do
want to continue at that rate they are
aiming for around a thousand british
nationals and locally employed staff to
be returned from afghanistan every day
the big question is the how they if
they're able to get on board we have
heard from our correspondent stuart
ramsey just the sheer difficulty at
getting to
the airport sky news has also been
speaking to a former royal marine paul
farving he's in
kabul and he's been describing how he
transported his wife to the airport they
had to go in darkness before dawn to try
and make it there his wife who is
originally from norway was able to board
a military aircraft and posted a
photograph from inside that plane which
appeared to show it empty raising the
question as to how many people are being
able to get on board the planes that are
leaving afghanistan paul farving himself
has vowed to stay in kabul
until his 71 afghan staff and families
are protected and also his animals and
as i said it does really raise the
question as to how many people are able
to get through the airport and get on
board one of those planes
okay charlotte thank you
breaking news we just had the latest
figures on government borrowing and debt
retail sales volumes dropped by 2.5
between june and july of this year but
they remained significantly ahead of
pre-pandemic levels now
that we're told partly driven by decline
in food store sales which were impacted
by return of hospitality
as well as the end of euro 2020 and the
impact that the football tournament had
more on that of course throughout the
day
here on sky news now
to the environment where greta tunberg
says claims the uk is leading the fight
against climate change are a lie earlier
this year the prime minister said
britain had reduced its co2 emissions by
about 42 percent on 1990 levels
but speaking at the launch of a un
report into the effects of climate
change on children the 18 year old
alleged that not all emissions were
included in official figures
jemima walker reports
it's been a year of extreme weather
events in all corners of the globe
but ahead of the cop 26 climate summit
greta tunberg is zeroing in on the uk
so i'm really hoping that we will stop
referring to the uk as a climate leader
because if you look at the reality that
is simply not true the government says
it's made big strides towards reaching
net zero the uk has been able to cut our
own co2 emissions by about 42 percent on
1990 levels but the young activists
calls that claim into question
there is a lie
that the uk has is a climate leader and
that they have reduced their co2
emissions by 44 since 1990 or whatever
uh and of course if you don't include
all emissions that's
of course
statistics are gonna look much nicer but
if you include things like aviation
shipping outsourcing and the
imports of
like consumption for instance and the
burning of biomass it doesn't really
look that good she was speaking at the
launch of a new unicef report
it finds almost half the world's
children living countries classed as
being at extremely high risk of climate
change impacts
it says 2 billion children are highly
exposed to air pollution
920 million are highly exposed to water
scarcity
and 820 million to heat waves
the report coincides with the third
anniversary of greta's first fridays for
future school strike
a movement which started with a single
child has since been joined by millions
more
activists like greta say children are
the biggest victims of climate change
and it's the adults at cop26 who need to
lead the fight against it
jemima walker sky news
let's have a look at the impact of
climate change on the planet right now
and the top line here is our real-time
power mix showing you just where our
energy in the uk is coming from at the
moment 57
fossil fuels vast majority of that
is gas renewables down to 19 at the
moment that fluctuates all the time
next line down is is the global warming
since 1880 and that since records began
you can see it's 1.23 percent actually
see how it's risen so steeply um over
the past
what sort of 40 50 years or so
and that's all leading to 1.5 degrees
that's the point of no return according
to scientists and the time left to that
say tellers they estimate
is not much more than 11 years and of
course a lot of that down to carbon
dioxide emissions the bottom line shows
you how much
co2
has been emitted into our atmosphere 2.4
million
million tons so far
okay well let's have a look at the
weather for you right now see what today
has in store joe wheeler good morning
what have you got for us
good morning well i'm afraid it's not
terribly good news as we go towards the
weekend the weather's going downhill but
next week next week we've got an area of
high pressure building in and that will
settle things down perhaps even a bit of
sunshine but let's take a look at what's
happening today
[Music]
look forward to brighter skies
the weather sponsored by qatar airways
yes it's an area of low pressure which
is working its way in and it sort of
meanders across the country taking its
fair old time not actually clearing away
until sunday and believe it or not it's
already here over parts of ireland it's
going to be edging its way eastwards
through the course of the day now it
only ever actually gets to southwestern
parts of scotland perhaps some showery
outbreaks as well for parts of wales and
the southwest so in terms of what's
happening elsewhere we've got a very
very mild start temperatures 16 or 17 to
start the day not a huge amount of
brightness around though there are large
amounts of clouds and sometimes that
cloud thick enough to give a little
patchy rain and drizzle here and there
but as we go later on in the day that
rain makes its way across to western
parts of the uk mainland and then
overnight still further it's going to be
a very wet day for central areas through
tomorrow
the weather sponsored by qatar airways
joe thank you still to come for you has
the west been too slow to respond to the
crisis in afghanistan i'm going to talk
to a former adviser to boris johnson and
an academic who's just escaped from
kabul in a couple of minutes
[Music]
now the government has given details on
how many people it is rescuing from
afghanistan the evacuations are
continuing from the airport in kabul
with soldiers dealing with a mass of
people including babies desperate to
leave the country well earlier the armed
forces minister james hippie reveal the
exact number being flown out by the raf
i can confirm that in the last 24 hours
963
people have been evacuated from cabal on
the royal air force airbridge
that's a significant acceleration on the
numbers over the previous 24 hours and
reflects i think that we're now fully up
to speed in kabul uh with military
border force and foreign office consular
staff all now up and running
and we're looking forward to delivering
similar numbers today tomorrow and over
the days ahead we are simply doing our
best to maximize flow each and every day
but as my colleague the defense
secretary has sadly had to say on a
number of occasions the reality is that
eventually the air bridge will have to
close and quite possibly not everybody
will have been got out that's what keeps
us awake at night that's what's
motivating to us to work as hard as we
are to ensure that those numbers are the
absolute minimum
well it also emerged this morning that
no one on the foreign secretary's team
rang the afghan government as the
taliban took over the capital last
weekend and i asked the minister
if the foreign secretary in his team had
been working hard enough considering the
crisis in afghanistan
i can only tell you what i see in the
meetings and phone calls that i have uh
all the way through every day have done
for the last week will do for the next
one and what i see is that from the
prime minister to secretary of state to
my junior ministerial colleagues around
governments to senior civil servants all
the way down to the brave volunteer
civil servants who have gone forward to
cabal from the border force from the mod
and from the foreign office is people
across the majesties government working
their backsides off in order to get
people out
let's talk to our political
correspondent tamara cohen i mean there
is no doubt particularly the people on
the ground are working their backsides
off to quote the minister there but that
does raise a lot of questions about what
is going on in the upper echelons of
government yes absolutely there's no
doubt that dominick robb did not return
from his holiday until the early hours
of monday and now we learn did not not
only not take the call make a call to
the afghan foreign minister on friday as
instructed by officials but that call
was never made at all because in the
words of the foreign office he gave us a
statement last night and it couldn't be
organized before kabul actually fell
perhaps failed to take into account the
seriousness of the situation mr robb
said himself when he returned back we
were surprised by the lightning speed of
the taliban advance and that's why when
his cabinet colleagues say look one
phone call would not have prevented the
chaos we see in kabul by friday the
afghan government were melting like ice
is what we heard yesterday why was the
prime minister going on holiday himself
on the saturday and whether or not one
phone call would have given them
precious hours to evacuate afghan
translators or whether the afghan
government such as it was had no
leverage left on friday we'll never know
but certainly it contributes to a sense
of drift in government on this issue and
we learn additionally today that the
most senior officials at the foreign
office the home office and the ministry
of defense were all on their holidays as
well yes the government say they were
covered by colleagues but certainly
there was no particular sense of urgency
it feels about the taliban advance okay
tomorrow for now thank you
now five days since the taliban took
control in afghanistan western
politicians are still facing criticism
for their handling of the crisis
the foreign secretary the prime minister
and president biden are accused of
reacting too slowly to events in kabul
well boris johnson's former advisor
craig dillon and dr liza schuster a
sociology researcher who left kabul
yesterday joining me now it's good to
see you both i mean
craig what has this week been like for
president biden i mean he certainly
stood his ground in the decisions he's
made but
he's come under an awful lot of fire as
a result
it's been a disaster um and it's been
the first time really that we've seen
him challenged in his presidency um up
until now it's been pretty smooth
sailing um and what we saw which was
quite an interesting maneuver from him
um was to sort of bunker down and go
into hiding and you know he hasn't been
doing it he hasn't taken questions from
the media he's done one interview um
with good morning america but they
didn't release the full thing they're
really um trying to figure out how to
get this under control um and the
interesting thing from an international
perspective is that you know biden is
acting more trumpian than trump ever did
um it's a very strange turn of events
in terms of that i mean that because of
course a lot of people are trying to
point the finger at president trump he
did negotiate this deal but of course it
didn't have to be enacted by president
biden certainly not to the to the time
scale that the withdrawal was i mean
can the democrats point any fingers back
at donald trump or not
not really and what we're seeing now is
fingers being pointed um between the
state department with the pentagon with
all of these people
that are trying to argue that you know
they they didn't see it coming and and
you know and that's why i think some of
these arguments that i'm hearing in the
uk about the british government being
unprepared you know when the pentagon
are unprepared who famously prepare for
everything um i think you can give the
british government a little bit of a
break uh when they were on their
holidays and they they didn't see it
coming if the pentagon didn't see it
coming then we can't expect anyone to
okay dr schuster
you've been there i mean you've been
there out in in afghanistan for a long
time haven't you you've been you've been
working out there for a decade or more
what was the situation like in those
last few days
well i can tell you that in the last few
weeks we saw it coming
um
when i first went out to afghanistan
this time around my social networks out
there
made it very clear to me that the
situation had changed that it was much
more volatile and that there was
significantly more risk
so perhaps if people had actually
listened to afghans they might have seen
it coming a lot sooner
do you have any confidence in and it's
not coming from from the from the blind
administration saying the taliban have
changed necessarily but we certainly
heard it from our chief of defense staff
over here do you
do you think the taliban have changed
have you seen anything or heard anything
to indicate that
their pr is a little bit better in that
they were engaging with the troops
around the airport and facilitating
some of the transport of foreigners to
the airport
but in the days that i was there before
i left colleagues were telling me that
they had been next door to the neighbor
they had been searching for official
documents they were working out who had
been working with the government they
had their lists their famous blacklist
which was a list of everybody from
director level upwards who had been
working with the government the taliban
has not changed
they are still beating people
there have been incidents of stonings
around the country
they are forcing women to wear the burqa
and if they leave without a maharan they
are being sent home again and may be
beaten
they have entered people's homes
they are compiling lists of unmarried
women between 15 and 45 as suitable
wives for their fighters
the taliban have not changed and if
western governments are choosing to
believe the taliban propaganda it's
because it serves their purposes but it
will come back and bite them in the ass
craig
in all of this
i mean when you hear accounts like that
and they're going to be more and more
accounts coming out over the coming
weeks
where does that leave president biden
when he effectively said the other night
you know this is
not our fight anymore
yeah it's a really difficult position um
that they've found themselves in because
the majority of americans tend to agree
with him um america tends to be very
very very insular um and only really
care about what happens in america you
know you watch american news and rarely
is there an international story um so he
is speaking directly to the people but
it's just not what we expected from
biden we expected it to be much more of
an obama-style presidency that was very
globalist in its outlook um and what
we're seeing now is a real shift on
internal politics um and what that says
for the rest of the world is is very
difficult as we saw theresa may saying
uh in the commons that what does it say
about the uk if that we can't do
anything unless america is doing it with
us i think it's uh it's time that the uk
start looking to their other allies
around the world from india to australia
to japan and creating some sort of
alliance that can uh that can work um
because america is doing its own thing
now yeah but i mean
we've come to a clear understanding that
america is the framework of nato and
without them nothing else is gonna
happen
yeah but we have to be prepared you know
there is a possibility that president
trump could run again and could win
again and do extreme things even more
than he did last time um and if he was
to pull out of nato um the uk and other
nato partners need to be in a position
uh to ensure that that alliance stays
together otherwise who knows what
happens to the world i mean liza do you
have any confidence that you are going
to be able to go back
i don't know i hope so i hope so but
probably not in the immediate future
um but one thing you can say about
afghanistan is that very little is
predictable it's very volatile
um there is a new generation of young
people that have grown up without the
taliban
and
all our hope resides in them they are
the ones that will make a change but if
they do it will be at huge costs to
themselves
but i believe that they will make a
change i'm just not sure when or how
okay liza schuster craig dylan good to
talk to you both thank you
okay time to have a look at all the
sport for you this morning a change of
tap morning jackie how are you
good morning very well thank you yeah
bit of a mixed old night in europe
though for the british clubs but for the
british women they're going very well at
the open golf let's have a look
chase the pack achieve your goals and
unlock rewards live life with vitality
and zwift the app that makes indoor
cycling fun this sports bulletin is
brought to you by vitality and zwift
welcome to scarman house here at warwick
university for your fa core return to
refereeing blue cone
genuine attempt for the ball no
defenders no defenders
well done in comparison to previous
seasons
not
a great deal of law changes in readiness
for the 21 22 season we've not got any
red cards looking at the floor i don't
really want to do that i'm really sorry
and we've not got it kind of
confrontational have it the key changes
really surround that whole aspect of
handball
at warwick university the fa's center of
refereeing excellence held a training
camp for a select group of officials
from steps two to seven who've been
identified as having the potential to
progress to the highest levels
referee recruitment for us as an
association has never really been a
challenge
ninety percent of the referees that we
recruit are below the age of 25 anyway
so that gives us a really healthy
youthful pool of referees to work with
to try and then nurture educate and
develop we look at the next generation
that are coming through so the help and
advice and support that we can give them
to help them to move on and improve
their game both on and off the field of
play is is key importance incredibly
valuable um it will mean that starting
the season again
i'm in a better place both mentally and
physically and yeah it's just really
beneficial to to push on the technical
session focused on the new handball laws
accidental handball leading to a goal
will only be punished if a goal is
scored directly it's only the the
accidental handball if it goes into the
goal or it's immediate and goes into the
goal from that attacking player who
scores it it just gives everybody a
little bit more clarity and it gives
football the the answers that they want
to see it doesn't slow games down or
possibly as we saw over the last couple
of years
some people obviously not agreeing with
the decisions ultimately the language in
the laws is as clear as can be but even
with that it's still open to
interpretation isn't it it will always
be a challenge and the certain things
that we say in life that we widely
accept you might have an opinion of what
that might mean and it might be
different different to me so i think to
get absolute
100
clarity
and consistency on certain aspects of
football will be a very very difficult
task but one that we're striving to to
sort of make better what was it that got
you into refereeing why did you choose
this path uh for me obviously i was
playing
and i
love football i think ultimately i am a
football fan number one
however i want to achieve the
my end goal which is make it as high as
i can football league premier league and
hopefully i was hopefully i'll do that
refereeing i was never going to do it as
a player i accepted that i knew that as
a as a 16 year old a lot of people say
to us that oh you don't play football
you've never played football and you're
not a fan but we are we're all true fans
at heart and we all love the game and it
is important that whilst we are fans
that we've played football that we know
knowledge and know exactly what we need
to be doing on the field of play because
it's different than playing football a
referee and we need to know exactly what
we need to be doing at any given
opportunity and get that right with fans
back in the stadiums for 20 21 22
perhaps officials will have a slightly
more pressurized environment to work in
but they will be prepared and ready live
life with vitality and zwift the app
that makes indoor cycling fun
jackie thank you still to come for you
this morning
[Music]
i'll be joined by the founder of the
afghanistan national institute of music
on the future of music under taliban
rule
[Music]
i'm alex crawford and i'm skye's special
correspondent based in istanbul
we aim to be the best and the most
trusted place for news
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
this is a forgotten front line they are
dying here
[Music]
boys we've got some interesting ways of
showing you what's going on their
message to us get ready
instructing you to stay at home
i can't believe we did that it's pretty
special isn't it
[Music]
i'm never lazarus and i'm skies reporter
based in delhi
we take you to the heart of the story
that shapes our world
[Music]
[Applause]
does anyone know which particular parts
of your body can be damaged by air
pollution
[Music]
the end of the week and the weekend is
looking like a bit of a washout but come
next week high pressure building will
bring us some more subtle conditions
before today after a mild start cloud
and rain will spread across ireland from
the west and it'll push its way in
towards southwestern parts of scotland
west wales and parts of devon and
cornwall by the end of the day elsewhere
largely cloudy
on the upside air pollution is going to
be low there's the potential for some
moderate pockets close to busy roads and
urban areas
the air quality report sponsored by
phillips air purifiers
the supermarket chain morrisons says
it's accepted a new 7 billion pound bid
from a u.s private equity firm
shareholders will vote on the consortium
bid
in october
the government says it will hold talks
with former gurkhas in their dispute
over pensions the veterans minister says
the protesters have agreed to end their
13-day hunger strike
a nationwide lockdown in new zealand has
been extended until wednesday they were
brought in this week after one person in
auckland tested positive for kovid 19
and the delta variant the first time in
six months
a suspected colombian drug cartel leader
has been arrested at his own wedding an
alleged logistics chief for colombia's
golf clan louis daniel santana was about
to tie the knot before police entered
uninvited and detained him the 24 year
old has been on the run since 2017.
so the afghan people face uncertainty
about what life is going to be like
under the taliban organizations like the
afghanistan national institute of music
which promotes gender equality and
freedom of expression
about are worried about whether or not
they're going to be forced to close well
dr ahmad samasth founded the institute
of music and joins me now it's good to
see you this morning
do you hold out any hope
that the institute can continue
uh given the post policies of taliban
against music i believe there is no hope
but i'm an optimistic person and
while hope is alive we should hope that
we might be able to resume of activities
and
there are speculation the taliban has
changed and i i would like to see that
the words and the action of of the
target but not responding to each other
how important has the institute been
because i know you've focused not only
on children who particularly deprived
but also of course an equality for for
girls and boys i mean all things which
we think are very important what impact
have they had on society in afghanistan
in the last 10 years afghanistan
national institute of music and various
ensemble and orchestras of our school
played a significant role not only in
promoting
music and revolving musical tradition of
afghanistan not only in
promoting musical diversity in the in
the country but we also have been using
the soft power power of music to
contribute to the reunification of
afghanistan and also building bridges
between the uh
between afghanistan and the
international community during the last
11 years afghanistan nationalist music
transformed the lives of many afghan
disadvantaged children
we had the privilege and the honor to
have the first all-female zora orchestra
which became a symbol of freedom and
emancipation women in afghanistan we
have we have the honor to train the
first female conductor in the history of
afghanistan and in the last 10 years
afghanistan national union staff music
and our various ensembles have been in
the full front of people-to-people and
intercultural dialogue between
afghanistan between afghanistan and the
international community
our ensemble and orchestras played
in 47 countries
and in prestigious concert venues such
as kennedy center carnegie hall
british museum
concert hall of radio sweden uh arts and
culture center of grebentian in
in portugal in many many places and
we've been
traveling the world
with the message uh to share the beauty
of afghan music with the international
community but at the same time to show a
positive side of afghanistan that has
been always overlooked in the in the
into international media
dr samus i'm sorry that we're out of
time it's been very good to talk to you
and i'd let's hope that afghanistan does
not fall silent thanks very much indeed
uh i hope that no one can it can silence
the afghan people again no let's hope
not thank you
okay let's have a look at the weather
with joe
[Music]
look forward to brighter skies
the weather sponsored by qatar airways
hello there good morning to you well the
weather's going downhill for the weekend
it's an area of low pressure which is
coming in from the atlantic it's going
to bring some wet weather that's going
to be very very slow to clear only
really getting away from eastern parts
on sunday so for today then it's a very
mild start not a lot in the way of
brightness but much of the uk mainland
staying dry the rain is already over
parts of ireland it'll reach
southwestern parts of scotland maybe
wales and the southwest by the end of
the day central and eastern part staying
dry
the weather sponsored by qatar airways
[Music]
so
[Music]
you